you're electric today I know I got
shocked by your electricity literally
literally literally naturally expensive
okay everyone welcome everyone to the
generator lien podcast hey guys thanks
for joining us today today's podcast is
brought to you by nature box with over a
hundred awesome really great in guilt
free snacks shipped right to your door
nature box gives you the option to get
some of the greatest tasting snacks you
can get let alone have shipped to your
house without you having to get off your
butt ah the best part about snacks is
when you don't have to go and get them
no one was enough to give us a chance to
appear yeah there's a snack in nature
rocks called mini Belgian waffles I
think that's all I have to say I don't
eat all those cuz I've never gotten eat
any of those no we've ordered more I
want these guys we need to get some more
snow fell job we'll talk to you some
more about hbox but ah they sponsor our
podcast so thank you guys you can get a
free trial at naturebox.com/tyler
Dooley sick sick sick awesome anything
around food like you got can always
sponsor the podcast cuz I love food
because they're so hungry for all the
snacks so hungry and hungry I don't want
to go get snacks I want snacks to appear
on my chest while I'm laying down
watching Netflix in the dark Josh I want
the snacks I just up here and then you
don't have to look at them right you
just and you don't have to look at
anything I mean you can look at the
label though because nature box is great
for you it's natural guilt-free no high
fructose corn syrup no crap in it mmm
um many of them are gluten free for our
celiac friends like Jillian that is true
I would not be telling you guys to get a
product that I couldn't eat myself hey
guys try these actual waffles that I
can't eat they're delicious yeah no
thank you
no um no gluten or No Deal so anyways on
today's podcast we asked you on our
Twitter what you wanted us to talk about
and like one of the most requested
topics was this Rachel Dolezal
who was the pet is
the head is that the name the president
of the movie chairman NCAP any double
and double AC p-- n w CP sorry for all
the caffeinated words right now
yeah in Spokane and it was revealed that
she was actually not a black woman and
that she had been pretending to be a
black woman so hopefully you all know
what we're talking about yeah and it
gets really good using the stories
Oliver on yeah so I mean apparently she
was pretending to be african-american
but continues to identifies black my
guess so which I guess is like how she
you know she feels like she's in the
grouping of black people
she likes to identify with who they are
what they go through but technically she
can't just identify as African America
that's what I've I've read like right
she's identifying his black but even
though she's out it is not
african-american she's still identifies
right mark and I think the people's
opinions on Twitter for the most of this
stuff I've gotten from Twitter and
articles and different things from
Twitter it seems like the general
consensus is that people are angry at
her and they're offended yeah or this is
hysterical which has been where mixture
of oh well there's been a really funny
reaction on the internet well the
internet really took it in there yeah
they're not letting go it's what I mean
it really is it's kind of like a bunch
of whatever way you want to unpack it
you know as a person I'm a Caucasian
woman you're a Caucasian man you can't
really speak to the fact I understand
why people I do understand why people
are offended by this yeah because she
was literally parading around in
blackface because she can and she was
able to get away with it I think some of
the more funny tweets have been black
people being like oh I'm a white
American male today like I would love to
have some good credit and be great at
swimming like that people have really
[ __ ] pointed out the uncomfortable
truth which is you can't really just say
I'm a different race now and I would
like everything that goes along with
that absolutely you know yeah I can
understand the anger I'm not angry but I
can
understand very clearly why someone
would be angry of any race right you
know it's it's a weird thing and it's
not something that you're you're not
you're not affecting other people by
doing it's not something you're doing
because you want to do this has an
effect especially when you have a
position of power right in any sort of
organization you're setting an example
for people so when you make decisions
like that there's going to be a wave
right and I'm like I don't really know
where to start with this topic other
than but my first exposure to it so my
first exposure to it was watching that
interview where the guy had originally
asked her if she was african-american
and she you know walked away I don't
know if you've seen that but you should
watch it it's good well I had a problem
with Moore was that she was describing
these hate crimes against herself and he
was sort of poking holes in the idea
that you know they were from Oakland
California but they weren't postmarks
like they hadn't gone through the mail
and that the only way that someone could
have put these like hate letters into
this p.o box or whatever was that they
had a key and she's giving this very
elaborate and like well-spoken answer as
to why she wouldn't do that as to why
that's ridiculous and you know for her
kids sake like no one would ever make
that up or do that that's insane and
just that in and of itself is really
ridiculous wild like you're being called
out for mailing mailing in quotations
yeah hate letters to yourself like she
wanted this attention she wanted all she
wanted the proof to exist that she was
dealing with the same thing that other
african-american people deal with right
and and I was reading about her
background that she had gone to Howard I
think at one point and somewhere were I
don't know where she got her master's
think it might have been Howard and she
was feeling like obviously this woman it
was African American Studies or
something she was studying a lot of that
stuff and that's what she has made her
life's work and it's depressing that you
don't have to
be an african-american person in order
to work and do good and fight for the
cause right yeah and she still chose to
yeah anyways I was getting somewhere I
just [ __ ] lost my that I feel like I
was doing that too it's a very weird
thing and honestly like you got to
wonder like what when she made the
decision to completely like turn into a
different race right she had apparently
told her adoptive brother to quote not
blow her cover yeah I mean what do you
save your him yeah um well I would slap
a [ __ ] and be like listen stop it I I
guess what I was trying to get to is
that what's more problematic than her
pretending to be another race although
that's very problematic is the like
level of what she's lying about and how
she's lying about it and how far down
the rabbit hole that goes yeah because
regardless of whether or not you're
posing as someone in a different race or
pretending to be something that you're
not it's generally frowned upon to live
your life day by day you wake up and you
end every single day doing nothing but
telling lies and it what's frustrating
is that she you know obviously does
really good work she [ __ ] cares about
police brutality and things that [ __ ]
matter like doing work every single day
to make this go away or be less of a
problem in this country and it's being
overshadowed by the fact that she's
being she was doing blackface I mean all
the one all the while I'm doing it you
don't need to do that I mean here's the
thing like all the while of her doing
great work and fighting for the cause or
whatever you want and that's just what
I've read that she does great work well
you know whatever but I don't think
anyone was she works for Andy what she
sucked well yeah it's not exactly it's
not coming out like that now but the
point is is like yes she she identifies
and she's trying to be a leader and help
change happen affect change in the world
but every single day that she went into
work and did maybe great work she's
being before that she's being selfish
right and so it's it's very like
counterintuitive to like you can't just
be someone he doesn't work like that you
can't just choose like today I'm going
to dress it's like it's offensive and
it's not right and it's incorrect and it
directly conflicts with the message
you're sending with everything else you
do so she has to at one point or she's
just nuts but she has to at one point
have thought like you know I'm I believe
in what I'm doing I believe in all the
things that I'm trying to fight for but
am I being a little stupid and selfish
by its very counteracting everything I'm
writing and with who I'm being the way
that a lot of people had framed it on
Twitter is that you know if she had not
posed as an African American woman yes
that job may have been given to someone
other than her yet you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah there was a story that
Kate like she was trying to apply for
some school or something no word how it
was Howard and she got resent she wasn't
[ __ ] I read the words sue but I don't
know if she actually tried to sue them
because she felt like they were
discriminating against her
for being white and not black and I
understand although not really I don't
want to say I understand I I'm gonna
take any time you hear me say I
understand I mean take that with a grain
of salt because I'm we're trying to be
understanding we're not identifying with
someone like this right um who
identifies with a different race she I
can't even make words the article that I
was reading theorized that perhaps
because she was so immersed in the
culture and she was so passionate about
what she was studying and what she was
doing that she developed some sort of
self-hatred
for being a white woman and that she
felt the only way that people would take
her words seriously and stop being angry
at her for being a white woman and as
opposed to a black one is to not be a
white woman anymore I would say Java is
logical it's an interesting theory but
that also doesn't explain why she would
lie about hate crimes or who her father
is
and things like that like that's why I'm
sort of on the fence as to whether or
not I think she's you know doing
something because she thinks she's being
helpful and so
like I think that she's [ __ ] crazy
she has an idea okay and she thinks she
you know first of all like you just said
the self-hatred thing I can kind of
grasp that where she feels like if I'm
going to be representing all these
african-american people and they have so
many problems with the way certain
Caucasian or white people act I can't be
that like I hate that I want to fight
for them against that right whatever so
I get that but like maybe she thought it
would give her some sort of more
legitimacy if she didn't appear
completely yeah okay yeah no I get here
to be mixed or of some level of
understanding but she does it well and
as much as I can get anything in this
situation that's something I can sort of
wrap my head around what I don't like
and what I think happened is like she
has this right she chooses to you know
act black and then it slowly just kind
of tumbles out of control
yeah you don't mean like she's so far
into it that she's like oh now I'm gonna
create this whole past now I'm going to
send myself hate mail like all this
stuff where it's like okay you were
doing one thing questionable very
questionable and now you're doing
thousands of questionable things to back
this questionable lie that you created
in the first place
and now you're going to get out and of
course you can't just like get away with
that so it's very weird and I think my
parents outed her yeah which i think is
important to know yeah it's like you you
lied so [ __ ] hard that you leave your
family no choice but to be like don't
listen to her we're the only ones that
can tell you for sure stop listening to
her although I record anywhere is
actually claiming I know that in one
article they read she had claimed to be
quote more mixed than cake batter which
obviously is not true wow that's a quote
yeah yeah that's a quote and a half no I
don't think she's ever I've never heard
or read that she says I am black I know
you know I've never seen that but maybe
it's there I don't know who knows it's
just it's frustrating and she didn't
have to lie and she chose to lie which
is what I thought she's the
laughingstock of the internet well yes
the internet is laughing and her right
now
a little bit deserves that I mean come
on I mean you know
well what I want to talk about right now
is the discussion that's going on with
Caitlyn Jenner and the transgender
community you know having a big surge in
positivity people now using the word
transracial to describe or trans Rachel
to describe what's going on yeah and why
it's not quite the same thing and
whether or not you agree or disagree or
what your thoughts are on that I'd love
to see in the comments because I
personally would like to take the stance
that I don't think the transracial is
the same thing as transgender I don't
think it's even in the same ballpark in
this in the ballpark being real I bet
the name of the ballpark
that's what transgender is this I read
someone so I have a bunch of screenshot
of tweets I want to read later but um
that someone has had said on Twitter
white people are making up words to you
know cover up the fact that they're
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] now you're saying
transracial is a thing it's not to put
the word trans in front of anything in
this situation is a little bit like [ __ ]
really it's kind of like really it's
like yeah really transracial that's what
we're going your trans Rachel I'm trying
to be careful on how I talk about this
whole situation
oh yeah [ __ ] weird what obviously
that [ __ ] I hate how it's like someone
does something so [ __ ] weird and
[ __ ] up and now everyone's like what
like how do I talk about it what do I
say
what is how can I be nad is difficult
whenever you're voicing your opinion
about something that there is specific
language and diction that you want to be
sensitive to and also be aware of but
like like I said in the beginning like I
can't I can't be angry at her for
pretending to be black because I'm a
white woman and regardless of whether or
not I would like to have it there is
such a thing as white privilege to know
I mean like there is a privilege to
being a white woman know for sure and
what people were saying Oh as to why
they were offended is because this white
woman has the privilege to choose to
pretend to be black and then make a
career out of that's the most offensive
part right
I would agree and privilege is like
something that we like to pretend it
doesn't exist it [ __ ] exists all the
time
absolutely you don't I mean okay nobody
rebel it is [ __ ] real it's real no
matter what you want to think it exists
right and by not talking about it
it's just as bad as denying that it's a
thing yeah so it is a little bit
difficult though to sit here and pretend
to do more or think more than like you
know what man I had a real good [ __ ]
laugh on Twitter and I think that this
woman is [ __ ] crazy and I think that
she's doing a giant disservice to
herself and to everyone around her by
lying and taking jobs away from people
or hurting people and the the mailing
yourself hate crimes is not doing anyone
any favors ever ever ever ever yeah uh
it reminds me of her who was I'm not
going to I want to see Tito Ortiz but I
don't think it might not have been him
but there was a fighter who was
struggling with his popularity and he's
kind of over the hill and he you know he
created Twitter accounts to send tweets
to himself of like fan made sure there
wasn't Tito Ortiz I think it's it was a
circus I just didn't want to like say it
was and then not be positive because I
haven't double-checks but see - Artie
yeah he created a fan account was
tweeting stuff at himself like oh you're
the best fighter ever loved and then one
time he forgot to log out of his account
and he sent fan mail like out as Tito
Ortiz and he got outed or whatever he
got caught and it just reminds you that
it's just like a very pathetic way of
accomplishing a goal that you're trying
to reach for Tito's it was Fame and it
was more popularity at his old age and
in his past prime in his career whatever
and for Rachel it's to become black and
deal with hardships in it and the hate
and the whatever you want to call it
that she tried to create and manufacture
for her fake black self okay so we can
make it a little lighter you screen
capped a bunch of tweets that you
thought were funny and we also wanted to
do something else in this podcast so
tomorrow she's doing an interview
she's finally going to break her silence
and do an interview with whoever [ __ ]
NBC whatever and they're going to sit
down and having it so I thought it would
be funny if we tried to act it out and
simulate how we thought it would go so I
would be the interviewer and you would
be Rachel Dolezal and we kill us all yet
is it Dolezal Dolezal if you don't
really know whatever I don't care about
it I'm just like I'm to wrap up our
actual like talk about this but I want
to read some of these tweets because
they made me laugh yeah but um I think
that the most of people are like angry a
little offended and like but you don't
gotta lie about anything yeah just be
yourself no need please be yourself yeah
and that is true across the board there
is zero wrong with wanting to be a part
of the team or affect change on some
team a group of people's behalf while
being who you are
it doesn't matter who you are right what
matters is what you were doing what you
believe in what you wake up every day
and play your time towards and for her
it was fighting for African American
rights and and fighting injustice in the
entire world and she felt that she
couldn't do that as a white woman or
whatever but I'm just saying like it's
never about that it's about what you
stand up and do and at the end of the
day that's what people remember right
and all this stuff like about her weave
in her hair and all that the spray tan
like that stuff's funny to me but what's
more hurtful is when someone lies about
who their father is to make us think
something else about you do you don't I
mean like girl if you want to do your
hair like that go for it like I don't
give a [ __ ] but don't tell me that this
is your father and that you're half
black when it's you're lying that's
that's what's crazy yeah you know what I
mean have you ever known a person like
that people are crazy
well they're a little bit nuts to be OK
in their own mind with that behavior
right that's what I'm interested to see
tomorrow with all the interviews what
exactly is your explanation for this and
someone was like could just be like a
really long extensive performance art
that she just pulled up for everyone who
knows maybe she has some elaborate and
serious question do you think she's
gonna go to the interview dressed but I
I mean does she not identify
his way anymore like how does that work
I put that too then I haven't heard her
identify hers you wouldn't put money on
it what is she gonna look like when she
shows up in the aviary tomorrow I would
think that she would look how she's been
looking me too for the past few years I
think that maybe she would apologize for
hurting anyone by lying I think she was
gonna apologize for lying and I think
that she's gonna try and deflect away
from the fact of her external appearance
you know that we're supposed to be
judged by the quality of her character
not by the color of our skin if she's
gonna go that route guys honestly that's
what my money's on my club and um I
think that she's going to just really
try and damage control and that it's not
about her appearance or her past it's
about what she spends her time doing
which I don't disagree with but I
disagree with what she hasn't explained
it and that in the fact that she's you
know hurt a lot of people that see this
as the ultimate white privilege
happening right now absolutely you know
what I mean absolutely what do you think
I I think she's gonna have to get up
there and and you know if she comes out
and she's just like you know I did this
because this and just do like defensive
she's gonna get torn apart in the
interview right you know if she can't
just write she's got to accept some sort
of blame and you know some
responsibility yeah and I know nothing
about the woman I know nothing about her
other than this whole this whole fiasco
this whole news story I don't know
anything about her I know what she does
but I've never heard her speak I've
never read her whatever you know I mean
so I don't know what kind of person she
is she may do something completely
different than I'm expecting but I do
know that she's she's got quite a hole
to dig yourself out of tomorrow when she
gets on on air she does but hopefully
we'll get some new memes well yeah more
than we've already got Yeah right before
we get to these tweets a little worried
about naturebox
so we've obviously if you guys have seen
the podcast with Shane that was sponsor
our neighbor nature box to a nature box
is one of the best ways to get snacks
and also not deviate from whatever
trying whatever fitness health plan
you're trying to stay on it's very
difficult when you get hungry and you
don't want to just like eat chicken and
spinach all the time they have really
healthy snacks there's no additives
there's known
natural there's no high fructose corn
syrup there's only natural ingredients
and you can read there's like you know
only a handful of ingredients in each of
their snacks some of their snacks are
like literally some of the best things
ever it's like these guacamole bytes
that we had last time what other thing
are they called the blueberry nom noms
yeah well so the nom noms are like
they're like they're like basically like
natural cookies without you know any of
the [ __ ] that you find in like real case
it's so good it's like it's like granola
its chewy it's fresh protein and that's
another thing they come sealed up in
that box
really fresh to your door right to your
door hundreds like over 100 snacks right
to your door what you do is you know if
you sign up for nature box you go online
you get to pick at you they have a whole
beautiful catalog while they're lovely
looking snacks they have sweet salty
everything you want and you pick and
then it gets delivered to door and then
you snack your face that your face off
nature box is seriously great keep your
metabolism going absolutely you guys
need some snack with some nation you
know for those of you travel a lot or on
the go for work all day it's it's a
great option because they come in these
sealed packages it's great stuff if you
guys want to start a free trial no money
needed you log on to nature box common
edge iliyan and you get your free trial
and if you like it the what the true
free trial is is a combination of one of
like handful of the most popular snacks
that nature box and what they do is they
send it to you telephone like it try it
eat it eat all of it in one sitting if
you want and if you like it then you can
get your subscription but naturebox
commented julie and so check that out
and thank you nature box first of all
Thank You nature box
alright let's get to some of these
tweets now mind you none of these tweets
on my own I stole them all from Twitter
so yeah just so you know they're all
just getting their old Julianne's
alright a limerick there once was a
black woman named Rachel no there wasn't
I'm probably most angry at the fact
Rachel Dolezal so Brenda's braids from
scary movie there's a picture oh my god
that's really funny huh
so is Rachel Dolezal white and gold or
blue and black I saw that one - that
one's good
most important thing I've learned from
Rachel Dolezal being exposed as a fraud
dudes have no idea how much can be done
with product this is very true though
this is very true really quick though
like her nerves yeah so like the one
where it's like all the bringing an ice
cream cone thing all the braids yet
dude that is intense a lot of work she
really sat there and she got all those
braids it's I mean she committed she was
all in she committed I declare February
29th as Rachel Dolezal day because it's
generally not a part of Black History
Month but every four years it pretends
to be her own mama outed her her own
mama that is the blackest thing that
ever happened obviously Emma Stone has
to play Rachel Dolezal in the inevitable
film about this mess in reference to the
movie Aloha Iggy Azalea ran so Rachel
Dolezal could fly to okay timeout while
we're on the topic of Iggy Azalea do you
remember when Azealia Banks tweeted at
her big deal Australia well yet that's
when she said it blew Australia yeah but
she said it was around was around the
Baltimore riots or earlier than that was
way before that yeah um I can't remember
but she said uh I love how idiot glue
Australia is being really silent about
all this black culture is fun but black
issues aren't blah blah blah little
Australia igloo so choosing Iggy Azalea
being but Rachel is very passionate
about black issues and black culture
it's just it's got [ __ ] my brain yeah
about black culture is fun for Rachel
it's like it's like if she was very
serious like it Iggy Azalea did the
groundwork that Dolezal has done then
she wouldn't gotten called out by
Azealia Banks cuz she does stand for the
issues not just the culture
take my mind hurts my mind my mind hurts
that's what we should call this podcast
my mind hurts uh okay I mean what's the
one that Tiffany's one what Tiffany's
son that Tiffany's I don't know what
you're talking about
Breakfast at Tiffany's I don't know what
I'm gonna get to it probably not the
topping our holy fudge I just saw a
tweet referring to Rachel Dolezal as
hashtag blackfish I'm done like she
black fished everyone i catfished on it
and then also there was a trending
hashtag on twitter called hashtag ask
Rachel to try and figure out which Rach
which race she was mary j blige didn't
need any hateration or holler Asian in
this what a dancer e be dance soiree see
both a and B my god you get that yeah I
do uh here what should be wiped down a
shoulders B chest C pants D shoes eat
all of you oh my god like what would you
do if you're black right loudly uh okay
these are some of the more serious ones
Rachel Dolezal did more than lie about
being blacks you faked hate crimes
against herself making it harder for
real victims to be believed which is
very true and awful if I identify as
white when I hold on really quick so for
a moment in time she thought her story
in her story having credibility it was
more important than actual people having
actual issues maybe because that's what
she did she gave more credibility to her
own face should it ever be outed she
would then take away credibility from
all those who actually have these real
situations happening to them just think
about that first why is that she's yeah
she's on some next-level drinking
drinking her own kool-aid um if I
identify as a white as as white when do
I receive my privilege three to five
days express shipping I need to know
hashtag transracial that's it that was a
hashtag transracial well yeah she's my
problem with transracial black folk
can't decide to be white when the cops
raid their pool party but a white woman
can be n-double-a-cp president
so if i say i'm transracial and call
myself white do you think employers will
finally call me back honestly anyone
with this transracial [ __ ] is just
ridiculing the struggle that transgender
people go through it's a sham
transracial wasn't a thing during
slavery oh my god
how's that for [ __ ] some real talk
Jesus Christ trans trans racial isn't a
real thing
and it's degrading to trans people who
seriously struggle and fight to be
themselves and be accepted please stop
pimp act in this [ __ ] the quizzes oh
ok but anyways I mean I'm still reading
to these the bottom line is that Rachel
Dolezal did not have to appropriate
black identity in order to support the
black community which i think is most
people's issue hmm yes so weird [ __ ]
podcast is a weird situation guys okay
it's weird for everyone that's why I
feel like most of the things that are
happening on Twitter is like all we can
really do right now is just make some
jokes and you know point out the obvious
which is like what [ __ ] [ __ ] what the
actual luck is happening from where I
said Rachel Dolezal ran a long con
to get to a place where she could she
could have higher status in a community
that she fetishizes oh fetishizes that's
that's that's intense that's a powerful
word a horrible word isn't it because it
ah [ __ ] it rings a little weirdly true
like that's the kind of issues kind of
obsessed she's obsessed with it a
community that she fetish that
fetishizes so she wants some status
within that community by not being
ourselves that's powerful
bingo-bango just a friendly reminder
that a black person passing as a white
person was once a criminal offense enjoy
your day I just keep thinking about
Rachel Dolezal in the braiding shop
getting her hair done dedication she
didn't go to a braiding shop she had
someone come to that her Instagram name
is Afrocentric femme no she was a
this for the long haul no it's not yeah
it was that came out like immediately oh
that's [ __ ] terrible all these
pictures of her look like she googled
what do black people wear and just did
that oh my god if Rachel Dolezal can do
it so can i I am now a white American
give me good credit the abilities well
and learns not beating me it's a quiz
what is this item remote clicker mode
control so I mean yeah it this is this
is a bizarre thing that I don't think
that you know we've dealt with as a as a
American culture population of people we
haven't really had a person do this on
this scale I think that we're all kind
of scrambling to make sense of it I
think we all want to know why yeah you
know yeah and I hope that she does make
right with some people that she probably
very seriously offended and hurt as a
result of her choices yeah and
selfishness because I think this really
does boil down to her being very selfish
and that there's no need no I mean no
there's no need to masquerade as
something that you're not because you
want to be I don't know taken seriously
or whatever means she's obviously some
degree of [ __ ] up I that's what I
think but really really really but at
the end it's very important to know how
to talk to somebody
ya know absolute like five people at the
end of the day it's important to know
that whatever you do whatever you spend
your time doing is what people will
think of you ass write what you do and
she recite week I know she sat down I
know you know which you know I I can't
say whether I think that's right or
wrong or whatever I think that she needs
to take some time to herself I agree and
you know all right so she sits down
tomorrow yeah okay you're the you're the
guest I'm Rachel yeah you're Rachel he
hasn't and I'll just be the host we
really role-playing though like no it's
not you okay
yeah you tell me what questions you
think they're gonna ask and I'll tell
you how I think she's going to answer so
Rachel who do you think you are do you
mean that as like a in like a offensive
way who do you think you are or like do
you think you are hmm
I think that she would respond I think
she's gonna hide behind what she does
for a living and what she spent her life
studying and doing I don't think that
she's gonna off the bat just say
anything about race uh where convenient
for her to hold off on that for as long
as well yeah well where do where do you
get off you really think that's it I'm
sorry I had to ask those you guy that's
an office reference but no seriously
it's like where do you get thinking on
him seriously we go um okay how long did
you think this was gonna go undetected
hmm forever I mm see I think in her
heart of hearts she kind of wanted to
get caught she kind of wanted the
attention I think that she wants to be
more important than she is I think she
wants people to notice her but that's
like deep down repressed like you don't
want anyone to know but it's almost like
a cry for help yes that you're doing it
yeah so I think that all of the the
mailing herself hate crimes and drawing
attention to herself fulfills some like
deep need for recognition yeah so I
think that she on the surface would say
you know I no one would have ever
figured it out if you guys weren't you
know digging into my past for no reason
because it's not your business yes but I
think in her heart of hearts she
genuinely wanted to come clean I think
she was hiding behind a masquerade that
she literally could not keep up with
anymore you know what I mean yeah and
why instead of one day when you like
[ __ ] just take a shower and look like
yourself and take your hair out you say
hey guys this is really uncomfortable
for me I'm actually a white woman and
like I've been fooling you it was easier
for her to do it
by having someone else do it for her do
you know what I mean by having someone
else be like hey you're not who you say
you are now you got caught because then
she never has to be the one that admits
like it's I don't know how else to say
this yeah it gets harder for her to just
come out one day and be like hey guys
I'm not who I said I was it's easier for
her to get caught you know I mean but I
think that she did want to have it off
of her shoulders at some point yeah what
is it like to have it off of your
shoulders you don't think Rachel I feel
bad asking you to be ready no you're
just like speaking don't ask me what
questions you think she's gonna be asked
well okay so aside from being in the
public eye and having everyone question
you and you in your actions do you feel
a sense of relief I don't want to keep
this up in him yeah I think she feels
relieved honestly um do you intend on
continuing a work for African American
rights
yeah she'll always do that she went to
school for that that's her life's work
but she did step down from her dream job
right I mean so who knows if that's her
dream job we don't know what she wants
to do what's your dream job okay um yeah
I think that she'll continue doing what
she set out to do she'll just ya feel
more comfortable doing it as who she is
and not who she thinks would be a better
person here's a message here's a
question I think she's definitely gonna
be asked what what is your message to
the african-american population out
there
I think she might apologize honestly she
owes some apologies because people are
angry and offended you know do you think
that you could potentially in the future
continue to physically manifest as a
black person and not piss people off do
you think that's a possibility
oh you I don't understand what you're
asking me like I'm asking Rachel Oh
saying do you think I know you're saying
you're sorry and I know you're getting
you got caught but do you like do you
think that this is is going to be okay
to do in the future not to pretend but
to just like act as a black person now
like okay so should Rachel get up in the
morning and continue to identify as
black but that's what I'm saying I don't
think that she ever said that she
identifies as black I think what she's
doing with her spray tan and her hanger
- that is her style choices the
physicalness honestly think that she
might defend herself and say that that
wasn't her trying to be a different race
it was just how I think she was she
would defend herself and say how I wear
my hair or the fact that I choose to
make my skin darker isn't meant to be
offensive what was offensive was the
lying although in a package deal it's
all offensive you're coming off very
coherent right now I feel like she's not
gonna come off nearly as well but well I
think that she will defend her physical
appearance as as huuge associates yeah
not coordinated anything right because I
then I've never heard her say no you're
right you know I'm a austrian-american
it's assuming to say something but I
mean obviously it's she did her she did
claim to be mixed yeah and so I think
that she was playing up her physical
appearance to appear to be mixed yeah
but I've never heard her say that's what
she identified yes so and I I imagine
that she will defend her physical
appearance as just the way that she
liked to look yeah I think it's because
you know who was more blackface than her
that tanning mom she was offensive ass
yeah what are you doing it's context
though it is very much context one thing
the best just like no you say like it's
not like how dark you make your skin or
the way that you do your hair
it's are you tricking people into
thinking that you're something that
you're not actively lying about the
context you I'm going to need absolutely
know what what's your one last thing are
you also Batman
I don't know I mean I didn't absolutely
watch it I'm glad we had this discussion
I'm glad we kept it light at times
because it's important I'm also glad we
talked real about it you know yeah it's
something that you don't really
experience every day right and and let
us know in the comments if you are
offended by Rachel please die all means
explain that and not I'm not that's not
like me demanding an answer no let us
know yeah where's your head up yeah if
you're offended let us know if you think
she's funny if she thinks she's crazy if
you think that this is you know a lot of
hullabaloo about whatever let us know
whatever your thoughts are where you lie
on the spectrum if you care don't care
if we missed any funny tweets or me yeah
diamonds because I think for a lot of us
that are just sort of grappling to make
sense of what's going on the best thing
that we can do is just kind of like have
a good laugh and then remember that at
least while some of her lies and deceit
were you know I don't think they were
malicious in nature they did hurt people
I think absolutely and that we don't we
don't need to completely vilify someone
who wasn't actively doing like really
really awful things she was doing good
things she was trying to be a good
person with the exception in my opinion
of the mailing her self hate crime
things and you know lying about her
family I don't think that she's the
worst person in the world and that you
know I think as a culture in a society
we can figure out what sense to make of
this when we hear what she has to say
for herself tomorrow no you know I think
you were really well spoken on this
broadcast oh fast also let us know your
predictions for the interview oh yeah
what do you think oh yeah oh so many
ways it's almost so many ways ah thank
you guys for hanging out for the this
episode of the Jenna Jillian podcast and
make sure you go you know click the link
in the description or just go to nature
box common of Julian get your song free
tracks I mean you could have been eating
snacks this whole pop you know what if
you get a free trial right now by next
week you can watch our podcast in just
munch the entire time
munching you're like you know what I
wasn't eating potato chips I'll get
lunch too much too much Tim Finn Tim Oh
Jesse and team Stabler always oh you
guys we'll see you guys next week on the
Jenna and Julian and Stabler podcast
team Casey Novak keep choosing splint I
am done kisses all right guys next yeah